It's great to welcome back to the program
bill share, who is contributing editor to
Politico magazine, an ardent
follower of a American politics as my audience
knows, sometimes to their pleasure, sometimes
to their displeasure.
Uh, always good to talk to you, bill.
Great to talk to you too.
So I mean, let's just start with the simplest
questions first.
Bernie Biden, Warren.
Does anybody else have any shot at this point,
either in a quantitatively defensible way
or qualitatively?
Yes.
Uh, I think, I think this is right now a two
person race between Warren and Biden.
Bernie has had a pretty rough couple of weeks.
[inaudible] and I, I don't think that his,
um, uh, medical or emergency means he can't
be president.
That's on my personal opinion.
And I don't know if that's the, the reason
why his numbers are down past couple of polls,
but, uh, you really see them being a much
more of a from third place up position.
Whereas the last Quinnipiac poll was worn
30 Biden 27.
So, you know, they're the top two and they
represent clearly distinguished ideological
positions in the party.
Uh, however, I don't think either one of them
is Holy secure.
Uh, Biden as we know, as has had all sorts
of problems, I think less ideological and
more performance based.
Uh, and if he continues to not seem sharp
on the stump, uh, he admitted he won't grow.
I mean, he hasn't grown in the past several
weeks.
Warren has only recently established herself
in the top tier, and she has not yet gotten
the front runner of treatment and she will
be tested.
No one's going to give her a free pass to
the nomination.
And the last time she had a rough go of it,
it wasn't 2018 with Trump calling her Pocahontas
and she responded with a DNA test and that
did not go well.
No, she, she may have learned since then.
It's, I'm not saying it's a given, she's going
to stumble, but she has not been tested.
And if she does not, whether the test, well,
both of them could fail and that opens up
the race in a big way for all sorts of potential
possibilities.
So one kind of polling question and then we'll
move on to some of the qualitative stuff.
Um, there are people who are writing to me
all the time saying, okay, David, I, I believe
Elizabeth Warren clearly has grown her support
over the last three months.
That's hard to deny.
But you're still seeing polls where sometimes
Biden is plus 12 and sometimes warn is plus
four.
Like how something has to be wrong with some
of these polls, right?
Well, yeah, they both can't be correct.
I think the, I don't have, I haven't gone
into a deep dive and it's like, well, this
methodology is access methodologies.
Why?
And that's what the differences, yeah.
I just think there's a degree of fluidity
here.
Uh, no one, we, I, I think both Biden and
Warren have their diehards.
I think they both have people who are sympathetic
to both of them for different reasons.
Uh, I think people are conflicted about who's
most electable.
They're conflicted about, uh, exactly how
far can you go policy-wise and still be viable
in a general election.
Uh, so people might be toggling back and forth,
uh, between the two and, and it's, it's not,
uh, clearly delineated, you know, moderates
over here progresses over here and let's have
it out.
Uh, so I taught so shocking that there is
some inconsistency in the polling, but I would
say there is over the scope of the national
polling, they are all generally saying Biden
worn in the top two.
Generally speaking, wore and having a slight
edge at this moment.
When we look at the debates, I and the dynamics
of the debates, first of all, I've found them
to be pretty disastrous.
I thought debate number three was maybe the
better one in that there was actually more
time spent on one issue where you could maybe
start to figure out which candidates are able
to go beyond three talking points, three bullet
points on a particular issue.
There were like 45 50 minutes spent on healthcare,
et cetera.
By and large though, I think that these debates
have been terrible, partially because of the
moderation and partially because there's just
too many people on the stage, including people
who have no shot at this point.
What do you think about the way the debates
have been run and whether they can actually
lead to better understanding of what the policy
knowledge is of the candidates versus these
for the most part, preplanned.
Gotcha moments.
Well, I'm, I'm old enough to not be waiting,
not be holding my breath for debate perfection.
Yes.
I mean there's all sorts of questions I think
should be asked.
I think would get to the heart of the matter
in a lot of ways and they almost never get
asked.
Um, but having said that, I think we're having
a fairly robust debate about the ideological
direction of the democratic party and the
best strategy of visa VI.
I'm confronting Trump.
I mean, it's not like we can't tell the difference
between Warren and Biden here.
Uh, and if you don't like w if you don't like
somebody either, there's two too.
You do have other options.
I mean, you know, Carmela's has had her moments
and Cory Booker has had his moments and budaj
as moments.
I mean, if you really liked those people,
you could be exposed to your support for them.
It's all like, you can't find out who those
people are.
Uh, so I, I don't think we are confused about
who these candidates are and what they stand
for, number one.
And number two, and this is maybe a bit of
a separate point, if there are people out
there that always can play all this takes
too long.
Why there's, why is there so much of this?
Why can't we be like Britain and have a two
week election?
It is valuable to put these people through
their paces and I mean you, you have a lot
of people, you got lot different kind of questions
to ask.
Love are different potentials for conflict
between the different combos and we're getting
opportunities to see all of that in action
over the course of the last several months.
So I don't like, we are in a position where
we don't know what's going on.
Like we have a good sense of where these people
are and where they stand and what they would
do in a general election and we got another
probably four or five debates to go until
we really make a final decision.
Yeah, we do.
I guess my, my concern is on healthcare for
example, it would be really great to be able
to, not in like a talking point who Leon Castro
has some thing to attack Biden with, like
to really dig into, okay, let's figure out
what the end point would be of the approach
that Joe Biden is proposing.
Let's let Bernie talk to Elizabeth Warren
about if she's open to Medicare for all but
not married to it, what specifically would
be the alternative and what would be the effect
on cost and you don't get that because you've
got 10 people on stage and it's half talking
points that that's I guess what I'm getting
at that there is no question that you can
discern the general difference between where
Biden is and where Warren is.
You're 100% right, but there are really important
questions that I would want asked on these
issues that we're just not getting to because
12 people get a chance to talk.
Well, I think we have learned that there is
a real difference of opinion within the democratic
party between a public option approach at
a Medicare for all approach.
You'll go into this, people might've thought
everyone was Medicare for all a and it's not
and it's, and that's a bad thing.
It's been fairly robust and it's actually
had some impact on the numbers.
I know a lot of your audience might be very
hardcore Medicare for all, and I'm not saying
you are wrong.
On the substance by making this point.
But the numbers for Medicare for all have
gone down.
Uh, I think it was a five points in the Kaiser
tracking poll, which asks the question about
public options, single payer approach every
month.
Uh, and I think that has something to do with
the fact that some bigger big names, Biden,
Buddha, judge and others have actually had
a pretty, um, forceful pushback on Medicare
for all.
Uh, now I think your point about the difference
between Bernie and Warren on that score has
not been very well explored.
And that's not the moderators fault or the
debate structure's fault.
The two of them have not wanted to go at it.
The two of them have been fairly hesitant
to really, uh, be pointed towards each other.
Now maybe that's different.
Tonight we saw Bernie take a, you know, a
bit of a swipe at Warren, but for being a
capitalist on a ABC on Sunday.
Yeah.
Uh, and now that he is clearly behind her,
he has a certain incentive to draw those contrasts.
And she has not been her weakest element in
her whole campaign has been answering the
question about would taxes go up on the middle
class in your health care plan?
Uh, and I don't think the argument, Oh, well
there's the, there be net savings.
So who cares?
Who cares?
The tax question.
I don't think that's sufficient.
I think everybody knows it's not sufficient
except for her diehard supporters.
And I would not be surprised if both people
on her left in Burnie and on her right her
on that because people want to see the numbers
and want to see your capability at defending
the numbers.
So there are people on the more moderate side
that would say, if you can't make this case,
maybe your argument is weak.
And there are people on the [inaudible] side
that say, Hey, if you, if you aren't gonna
really make this case, maybe you're not really
committed to it.
And so I think I would not be surprised if
that, I mean I would bet the moderators would
try to draw this up, what the candidates will
do.
I can't predict.
Well, I, I did a story early last week where
I looked at the numbers of, uh, each candidates
sec the, the supporters of each candidate.
It's second choice.
And what those numbers suggest to me is that
Bernie Sanders is not really going to be able
to make up the gap by going after Biden, particularly
because any damage he does to Biden based
on the morning consult poll will sort of be
evenly split between him and Elizabeth Warren
Biden, voters like Warren, slightly more than
they liked Bernie.
So mathematically, and I'm not suggesting
this become, you know, a poop flinging whatever
between Bernie and Warren, but mathematically,
I don't know how Bernie recovers without directly
trying to go after Warren support.
How do you see that?
Yeah, this is a, this is a bit of a catch
22 for him.
You know, we haven't seen anyone go out after
war and yet in a very concerted way of Buddha
J just kind of starting to, um, but everyone
was going off going after Biden has not reaped
the benefits of that.
Now maybe Biden has been damaged and so because
of it, but Camila, Gillette brand, Castro,
Booker, none of those guys have really benefited
by being pointed in their approach to buy
it.
And that has to weigh on Bernie if he is going
after war in a very deliberate way.
And there's upside and downside risks to that.
But I think you're also right.
I mean, Warren has to stumble for Bernie to
get back into the top tier.
Uh, and he has to decide does he forced that
issue?
Does he hope somebody else forces that issue?
Foreign policy, I feel like has been a relatively
absent from the conversation.
There are criticisms of what Donald Trump
has done in his doing visa be a Russia, Ukraine,
the Kurds, et cetera.
Um, and I've identified that foreign policy
is also not Bernie nor Warren's strongest
areas.
So I'm wondering where you see the foreign
policy discussion, whether you agree that
when it gets into the details Bernie and Warren
don't do particularly well on foreign policy.
You know, I, one of the surprises to me in
this race so far is that Biden has not been
able to play that card because he's the only
person on that stage with considerable foreign
policy experience.
Right.
And I would've thought that would've created
more of a stature gap, uh, on the debate stage.
And it's, and granted, foreign policy rarely
is the issue in a primary, not to mention
the general, uh, it hasn't been the topic
of discussion in most of these debates, but
it has come up and when it has come up, uh,
you know, Biden has not knocked it out of
the park in a way.
Whereas I would say there are points when
it was Hillary versus Bernie.
When foreign policy came up, she was running
circles around them, uh, and that w and that,
uh, not the reason why he lost biting that
definitely was not a help to him that he didn't,
he seemed a bit out of his element in that,
in that regard.
Um, and it's not to say that it's an ideological
point between being for military force or
being a skeptical military force.
I just think fluidity in language, depth of
knowledge that was exposed there.
Um, so, so long as Biden can't show I knowed
foreign policy a hundred times better than
these other folks.
Beyond that, it's kind of a wash unless somebody
sends something really, really Biffs it seems
like they really don't know what they're talking
about.
I think this is part of by, I mean aside from
whether you ideologically like Biden's foreign
policy ideas, which is a different issue.
This is where I feel like Biden looks slowed
down as you've talked about the, the, the
sort of optics of Biden during the debates.
I would have imagined that on foreign policy
he would be making it very clear that he has
both the experience and at least well staked
out positions.
Even if you disagree with them, there's sort
of a, a pattern that he has a worldview into
which his policy ideas fit.
The fact that he's failed to do that is to
me one of the bigger signals that he just
generally seems slowed down is the best way
that I can put it.
I mean, I would improve it in those terms,
but I, I totally get that people have that
takeaway and the more people have that take
away, the harder it is for him.
Now I saw that video that the Trump folks
push around when he's talking about how he
twisted the arms in Ukraine.
Yes.
To get rid of the prosecutor.
And of course that's being used to falsely
assert that he did something on toward a,
and when I look at that video, I say he looks
strong.
He looked sharp.
He was executing foreign policy that was directed
by a both Obama and backed up by our international
allies and he got done.
What he, what he sat to get done.
And those are the kind of anecdotes that he
could really use in a primary to show.
I've been there, I've done it, and I've made
things happen.
And it wasn't like that was 10 years ago.
That video I think was from a year ago.
I mean, I have a hard time believing he has
slowed down that much in a year, but the fact
remains, he hasn't come across that sharp
in these debates, uh, on foreign policy and
another issues.
By what date do you believe it will be clear
who the nominee is going to be?
Well, that's a little hard to say right now.
So if you look at the, the early state polling,
your CBS you give just had pulls out this
weekend where Iowa was a threeway tie.
Warren [inaudible] Warren at 22, Bernie a
21.
Warren had the edge in New Hampshire and Biden
had the edge, a massive edge in South Carolina.
We've seen much less polling in Nevada.
I think the last thing I saw me, Warren had
a bit of an edge.
They were white, but it was still in the mix.
Now I won New Hampshire are almost completely
white, very liberal, very college educated,
electorates that is the Elizabeth Warren sweet
spot.
You know, she needs to win.
Um, at least one of those two.
Uh, so those are not great States for Biden
if he, and right now the expectations setting
on Biden has been lowered.
So if you won one of those too, he'd be in
fantastic shape going into South Carolina.
So if by Tico in Iowa and eco in South Carolina
showing he could, which is a majority, uh,
African-American state, it is a much more
moderate conservative state electorally, uh,
if he could win there, I think he'd be very
poised for a strong super Tuesday, which is
only a few days after the South Carolina.
And maybe even effectively wrap it up at that
point.
Uh, if Biden lost Iowa, New Hampshire, maybe
in Nevada too.
And then when South Carolina, maybe you do
okay on super Tuesday and you'd have a bit
of a dog fight between him and Warren or him
and Bernie or whoever's, whoever won the other
contests that could drag out till the end
of the contest, which makes your convention
very, very dicey because the superdelegates
can't vote on the first ballot.
And so you might not have a majority winner
on the first ballot and the supers come in
on the second ballot.
And then at the end there's a broker convention.
It's crazy town.
Uh, the other option is somebody wins Iowa
and New Hampshire or it looks like the most
likely possibility at that point.
And then that person runs the table super
Tuesday.
Then you're basically done by March.
That's the sort of the John Kerry model.
Uh, what's different between now in 2004 is
South Carolina was not, did not have a standalone
date in February, in 2004.
And South Carolina is demographic demographically
very distinct from Iowa, New Hampshire, a
less so it with Nevada.
So we haven't had a situation where there,
that dichotomy presents itself.
We don't know how exactly that plays out.
Super Tuesday and beyond.
We will be watching it.
We know bill Sharewell as well.
He is a contributing editor to Politico magazine.
Bill, always a pleasure having you on.
Great to be here.
Thanks so much